and we're live hello everyone Welcome to
our live ask me anything session with a
team that brought to you hug and face
audio course
so today we are happy to answer your
questions about audio about the course
uh if you have already tried to
um practice your skills and have
encountered any issues so have any
questions go ahead drop them in the
YouTube chat and I'm going to start by
introducing the team so today we have
sanchi who is a machine learning
engineer for audio in the open source
team at hacking face
we have VB who is a machine learning
developer Advocate at hagenface focusing
on audio primarily
we have uh matais who is also a machine
learning engineer for audio and also
author of a book on how to write sounds
synthesizers
um and he also creates plugins in his
spare time
and
um I'm joining as well I have been
leading this project to bring this
course to you and today we are gonna be
talking well not talking we're gonna be
listening to you to your questions and
then trying to answer them uh to the
best of our abilities
um before we get to the questions
um I want to pass the mic to VB and he's
gonna
um say a few words about the course in
case uh you haven't started yet and you
are wondering what to expect
go ahead I'm going to add your slides
perfect
um can you see my screen
or is my screen up
yes yes we can okay perfect all right
good morning afternoon and evening from
wherever you all are joining us from
um I'm just gonna take a quick maybe
like a minute or two and just like walk
us through like what exactly do we cover
in the course so far
um so
at a 10 000 feet like the hugging face
audio course
um essentially like walks you from
um you know what can you do from um an
audio and like you know what all kind of
Downstream tasks can you perform with it
right so this involves doing
um classification this involves you know
doing uh speech recognition and you know
later on we'll be covering certain
things like text-to-speech
um and you know other audio related
tasks
um the course in itself like expects
very little uh background so um
essentially we we start off with uh
understanding what exactly audio is like
you know um what
is an audio waveform comprising of how
can you represent it and um you know how
do you work with it what are certain
libraries that you can use
um and so on right so the so the first
unit essentially covers that like how do
you load an audio how do you pre-process
it how do you stream it
um and we have certain quizzes and
certain
um readings that you can go along with
um with the course
um with each unit to test how much
um you know about
um this this specific unit
um and so so we start off with like how
do you work with audio data then we
um then the unit 2 is essentially as
soon as you understand what exactly is
um is audio then we're looking to
certain applications of it so for
example how can you classify audio how
can you you know use
um the hot and face ecosystem to you
know essentially use pipelines which is
our abstraction on certain
um you know specific use cases like
classification speech recognition
um you know and extracting embeddings
and so on like how do you essentially
use all of those and um you know then we
move over to what kind of architectures
for audio exist so you know um
we we go through what exactly is a
Transformer type model
um and you know just essentially provide
like a refresher on it what kind of
architectures are typically used
in
um in audio
um and yeah and that's like up until
unit 3 we essentially work on the
foundations
um that you need to know for you to be
able to maximize
um you know on your use cases and like
you know essentially understand
everything else from it
um and then unit four and five
um unit four essentially covers how do
you uh build a audio classification
Pipeline and we have a fantastic sort of
music genre classifier that we uh that
we go through
um and at the end of both unit 4 and
unit 5 you essentially have your own
sort of fine tune model for a specific
task
um so you you go through like code as
well as like understanding for building
um such use cases
um yes and just to wrap it up unit 5
which is something that we released
yesterday is on speech recognition um
wherein we we cover like how do you use
um models like whisper to create your
own uh speech recognition
um Pipelines
right and many more to come so we're
going to release the unit six next
Wednesday and um and so on so stay tuned
for that
happy to take any questions on that
thank you for this overview
um I think we can start with the
questions that we already received on
Discord
um the community has already started a
thread with questions and let me just
bring it up to see what is there
um the first question that we had was
whether we have any plans in the long
term to add more cool courses or expand
expand the current ones
um excellent question
we have lots of ideas for
um courses that we could potentially do
so there's some modalities that we
haven't covered yet there are some
Advanced topics related uh to production
performance improvements and things like
that that we haven't really touched on
um there's also of course the other end
of the spectrum the foundational topics
that we normally don't cover because we
usually cover more advanced topics we
expect people to understand the
foundations of deep learning machine
learning um
however whether we're gonna add any of
the courses really depends on a lot of
factors
um adding your courses is usually a lot
of work and it involves multiple team
members
um
and we have to can carefully consider
whether we want to prioritize creating
this kind of educational content on top
of already existing documentation and
notebooks and examples that we have or
whether we need to prioritize other
projects and so I cannot give you a
definitive answer unfortunately whether
we're going to have the courses
we certainly would like to but we at the
beginning of every project that we are
considering to start we are evaluating
the priorities and then re-evaluating
them again so
um when we get to the point that we're
considering another course then that's
when we're going to decide whether we're
going to have it but we do have lots of
ideas of what we could do and so
sorry that I can't give you a definitive
answer on that but we're definitely
considering more courses
um I hope this answers the question to
an extent
um and then with that I'm going to go to
the next question
which was
um
I work with neural time series data
uh EEG and fmri which are technically
very close to audio signals and I'm
interested in using Transformers for
this type of data do you know of any
applications of Transformers in analysis
of neuron time series data in my
experience Neuroscience lacks usage of
advanced ml models and it would have
been very beneficial for the field if
you had a course on that or an extension
to this audio course where neural time
series data were used as an example
um I wonder if somebody from the team
would like to answer this question
no I think it's a very valid question I
think what you said about the similarity
between audio data and any kind of Time
series data holds so I think the way to
view the audio course is to
think about mapping from
um like a Time series domain to another
domain and so you're doing the sequence
sequence mapping
and you can use the audio course as a
way of learning the fundamentals there
and then it's kind of agnostic to
whether you change that input and your
output so if you change what you're
mapping from into it doesn't necessarily
change the modeling part the model is
kind of agnostic to that in the same way
that a lot of what we call cover here is
actually very similar to computer vision
like we've spoken a lot about male
spectrograms which are basically images
so a lot of what we're doing is actually
just like an image classification
problem or image to sequence problem
um so I think the audio course gives you
like a nice fundamental fundamental
understanding for how to maybe apply
these models in in a different field
regarding Neuroscience my experience of
this little experience I've had in the
field of computational Neuroscience
there's a lot more emphasis placed on
understanding and interpretability of
models
so the whole point of what like a one is
that the the a big Endeavor in
Neuroscience is trying to understand how
the brain works and these machine
learning models might emulate tasks that
the brain does but it's very hard to
understand how they work and so
interpretability remains quite low which
personally is one reason I think
Advanced ml techniques are not applied
in the same way to Neuroscience that
they are
Say speech recognition we don't need to
necessarily know how the brain works to
transcribe speech but if you're doing
Neuroscience probably do need an
understanding of how those models work
which is why you favor
simple linear architectures or
models that you can probe and look
specifically at the weights and the
layers and the convolutions and and try
and understand what the model is doing
if I may add something to this um there
was a recent post on hugging faces blog
exploring Auto former which is a
Transformer architecture for time series
and I know that there are two more or
maybe even more than two at least two
more Transformers for time series that
hugging face supports one is even called
time series Transformer and the other
one unfortunately I forgot in in the
moment what it's called but
um
there are several Transformers
specifically for time series and the
recent blog post explores efficiency of
autoformer
for this kind of applications and I
think it's worth looking into and
exploring them as well in addition to
um audio Transformers for example
I'd like to add something as well
because there's something you have to be
careful about if you're using an audio
model for something that's not audio
because sometimes these models make
certain assumptions about the data so
for example a male spectrogram might not
make sense unless you're actually
dealing with audio because the transform
from spectrogram to Mel is based on the
human perception of sound which it
wouldn't make sense if you use that on
other data that's not audio so that's
something to be careful about
so you might not be able to just take an
existing Audio model and use the
different data you would have to make
sure that any transforms that happen
inside the model any pre-processing
still make sense for your data
absolutely makes sense the model
designed for specific modalities usually
have some
um
expectations
for what the input is
um and I think with that we can move on
to the next question
uh and the next next question is
um what are the current challenges of
audio machine learning and what is the
most exciting
um soja state of the art in this field
right now
anybody wants
to take it It's tricky to get consensus
on that no because every paper says I am
the current state of the art but maybe I
can quickly talk about text-to-speech um
and and then you know Sanchez
automatized if you want we can talk
about like speech recognition and so on
uh but quickly about text-to-speech
um in terms of like the current state of
the art in terms of closed Source
systems we have
um the sort of new breed of models which
is taking a text um and taking like you
know instead of using spectrograms as a
representation or just directly modeling
waveforms we model semantic tokens of
um the waveforms and essentially do like
language modeling style learning as we
do in text for audio and you know bark
is a very good example of IT music gen
is also a very good example of it and
um you know these type of techniques are
now like more and more models are are
adopting these right and that's pretty
much like where the sort of industry for
or where industry and Academia for
text-to-speech is moving so now you
don't see see like as much as
um you know fast so more like you know
um Taco Tron or you know Auto regressive
um types like previous models which were
conditioned on metal spectrograms and uh
so on uh just in terms of like Purity in
terms of numbers uh the natural speech
to paper
um by Microsoft actually claimed that in
terms of pure mean opinions course which
is a measure of how good the quality of
the audio is they surpassed human
um level evaluation
um again like there's there's more to
sort of read into it but that's just to
give you an understanding of that we're
very very close to uh you know mimicking
audios and so on and you can see that
with
um you know startups by the likes of 11
Labs uh play HD and so on that you know
they're able to have really high quality
speech which is often indistinguishable
and so on
yeah
I guess regarding speech recognition we
could have had like a big wave in the
last couple of years it's the first wave
to that two really opened the doors for
pre-training fine tuning so if you come
across birds or gpt2 there's the same
paradigms that really led to the
explosion in NLP we saw that for the
first time a few years ago with waves
vet too and then whisper
um kind of was an advancement and a step
forward based on that and um so it's
definitely a case that uh it's very like
exciting time in audio in general it's
seeing that big
boom in models that we saw a few years
ago in the LPN lots of breakthroughs and
advancements
um and speech recognition is probably a
little bit ahead of text-to-speech in
that regard like uh model maturity is a
bit higher you see like a ton of new
text speech models come out every week
with ASR there's pretty good consensus
that whisper
is the best
open source speech recognition all
available
um but there are still new models coming
out like MMS which came out a few weeks
ago by meta and it's a development on
way to vet too and it's better it's
better in some cases for very low
resource languages
and yeah I guess we're seeing also the
field of now just general text to audio
generation so it's all uses exactly the
same things that Vivi mentioned with
text-to-speech but you just generalize
instead of generating speech you can
generate any audio some music sounds
whatever
I also think that um you know there are
challenges with stuff like text to audio
or text-to-speech in that text is
it doesn't have a lot of information or
it misses certain information right so
if you have a sentence you could read
the sentence in many different ways
um and it's It's tricky to model this
just from text so I think we'll we'll
see more
um uh work done in that area as for like
a music generation I think one of the
big problems is that uh generation of
images works very well as we've seen
over the last year or two uh these
models make absolutely beautiful
pictures but the music generation models
they they don't make very convincing
music just yet
um they've been getting better but maybe
the problem with making music is that
our eyes tend to fill in things for us
so pictures uh is easier to make a
picture that looks convincing than just
to make music that sounds convincing
there can be many little details wrong
in the sound and we won't like it and I
think maybe
um that's one of the challenges for
music music generation models is that
it's it's a little bit harder to create
music that sounds convincing than it is
to make pictures that look advancing but
maybe we'll we'll see some interesting
developments of this or interesting
improvements
um you know people have been putting
more effort into the graphics and images
a side of things than into the audio
side of things so
as as more attention goes into the audio
uh into audio generative models maybe
we'll see some some great events was
there
um it's interesting times
I like that you touched on music
your comments because our next question
so it nicely segues into our next
question
um which is
um
uh for me I'm not interested in music
what are other applications or cool
things for audio I can build can you
give me some examples that are helpful
or cool
um what things to keep in mind when
trying to build a model for mobile
applications for voices
and on top of that there's another
question about visualizing uh in 3D
but I think we can split it let's let's
keep
um first the part with the examples
which are not music and I think we've
touched a little bit on speech but maybe
Beyond
um speech and music can you think of
other applications I can mention one
that I personally really enjoy and this
there's
um there's probably more than one but
there's this um app that recognizes bird
sounds and I can identify birds in your
area so I personally enjoy using that a
lot and I know that in conservation
projects
studying identifying animal species can
be used with audio
um but they're obviously many more
applications sound is everywhere around
us so what are some cool applications
that you can think of
I guess the cool thing about what we've
done in unit four in if you if you've
read the audio classification chapter
then the application Maria just
described of classifying bird sounds you
could you could theoretically do with
the fine tuning scripts and the
knowledge that you've obtained you just
have to swap out the data from a music
data set to one where you've got Birds
and the labels instead of classifying
what kind of music genre that the bird
sounds so um
like it's it's kind of yeah I think uh
so far audio class Well audio
classification in particular is kind of
categorized into three sub genres we see
mainly speech music and sounds like
sound classification
um but this is just like one piece in
like a in a bigger pipeline so um I
think if if you're like interested in
speech you can you can think about all
the little components that you can put
together to maybe build your own uh like
voice assistant so you have audio
classifications to recognize a wake word
and then speech recognition to
transcribe what you're saying and then
text-to-speech when the voice assistant
replies and all of this at every stage
in that process is an audio application
um they're just different tasks within
the audio domain
um but yeah there are loads of exciting
just even sound classification tasks as
well
so one one application of this
um it's
it's a type of classification but it
it's more like the domain of anomaly
detection so you can have
little microcontrollers for example
listen to The Sounds your machines make
in your factory and when they certainly
start making different sounds obviously
something's wrong with the machine and
it's kind of an easy way to detect if
something goes wrong in your factory uh
even if you don't have sensors on those
machines for example because everything
makes sounds and if the sound's
certainly different that might be cause
for an alarm so that's one one thing
that's actually being used uh in the
industry
I remembered another application for
audio sound for
um audio classification which probably
can come as a surprising application and
there were some researchers that studied
the sounds that tomato plants make when
they're in distress lack of water other
kinds of stresses they apparently we
don't hear those sounds because they're
at a frequency that we don't register
really but um some things happening like
maybe cells are popping because of lack
of water that they can record actually
and they can classify based on different
stressors so even if you you know cannot
really hear the sound that doesn't mean
that you cannot apply
audio approach to it
um just have to be I guess creative in
how you in how you approach a problem so
there's another unexpected probably
example of using audio
yeah and I mean just just one quick um
some example which I um just remembered
is that you can so even though like you
know it's like you don't want to deal
with same music like there's like an
entire field of Music transcription
um so like you know converting sort of
proper music and like you know all like
removing the Acoustics and just looking
just focusing on the vocals and like
getting the transcription of that
um is is um is like something which is I
could feel which is popping uh right now
and then of course as someone to
mentioned there was this um entire um so
like there is classification then
there's you know like of course
text-to-speech like on uh device and
then you know
um um also things like voice conversion
um so you know just adding like filters
that you see on Snapchat or Instagram on
your uh on your voice is also something
that you can do on device
um using quantized models we do have
some of those on the Hub um so you know
search around and um definitely play
around with those
um
thank you I see a question on the
YouTube chat about who's choosing the
questions and I want to clarify that uh
we're going first for the questions that
we have received uh on Discord
um and then we're going to switch to the
questions from YouTube
I think
we'll have plenty of time time for uh
all of it
so don't worry uh we'll get to the to
your questions
um
and so let's just continue with the next
one
um
whether we have a guy to fine-tune
Transformers on another language I think
this is a very quick question to answer
essentially do you want to take this one
yeah check out unit five and that's your
that's your guide
yep that is exactly what you're looking
for so this is um covered in great
detail in unit 5 and so we can jump to
the next question
um can you please share best known
practices for fine-tuning pre-trained
hugging face models what are the
recommended practices to debug loss
metrics and do hyper parameter tuning
specifically what are techniques to
avoid overfeeding I think maybe we can
try to answer this question briefly
because it's not exactly related to
um audio
but still it would be nice to give like
a couple of helpful tips
who wants to take it
yeah
all right so um like that so it's a very
it's it's this half science half art
training machine learning models and so
you have to fundamentally understand
what you're trying to do
and your objective is to your objective
is to
maximize slash minimize your evaluation
metric
um and you do this through a proxy
metric which is your loss so your
training loss you want to go down over
the course of training
um and
the art of looking at a loss curve and
knowing yes is this going in the right
direction am I starting to overfit have
I set the learning rate right have I set
the batch size right you can only really
get through experience
um there's not really a hard and fast
rule that you can apply to every system
like I know from fine tuning uh CTC
systems that they intrinsically have a
different Oscar from sector sequence
like whisper and I look for different
things when I'm debugging
um and there's not necessarily like
something that covers everything but
there is a really nice
um Playbook by Google that they released
a few months ago and this kind of gives
you the the most important knobs and
dials that you probably want to play
with so there's a batch size uh learning
rate drop out and your learning rate
schedule like how long do you want to
train for and so these are the things
that you probably want to start looking
at and so I'll send a link for for that
in the chat
um
maybe he can say that
yeah I mean I was just
okay so uh just one quick um thing yeah
um I was just gonna say that you know
like um in general like for all of these
things it's it's very important to you
know like sort of essentially like look
through
um
um and and like record as much as you
can so if you're using like um you know
um the hug and face stack uh like make
sure to like set one to be to true so
that like you can record all the logs in
like um in want to be and like
essentially like compare between your
different runs right and a good idea
um is to essentially like um you know
isolate um your sort of train data uh
and and then like Loop like like go
through different different parameters
and then like see like what what sort of
influences your um your output
um uh much and like you know you can
also sort of like look at certain
predictions whilst the uh models
training as well
um so you know um in general like I
would recommend just like recording
um you know as much as you can and like
locking as much as you can so that like
you have a more holistic idea of um how
your trading runs are going and compare
them later on
yeah all I wanted to add to this is that
the question asked
the best known practices for fine-tuning
hugging phase models
um it doesn't really matter if the model
is hugging face or not all these things
they work the same way so you could use
the hugging face uh the trainer or the
accelerate library to train the model
um you could also use
some other Library like uh Python's
lightning or write your own training
Loop whatever
um whatever you're comfortable with or
whatever makes sense for you
all these all these different pieces
they can all interoperate together and
work together so it doesn't really
matter you don't have to use the hugging
face strainer for example although it's
quite convenient and it's probably a
good place to start
thank you so we're gonna we're gonna
have two more questions from Discord and
then we're going to switch to the
questions from the YouTube chat
um one question which I think is also
going to be pretty straightforward to
answer hopefully
um whisper does a good job transcribing
General conversation but when having a
domain specific speech it fails to
recognize some words
um what would you recommend to deal with
new entities and words
because you wanna I think you've
yeah so one way to do this is to use
prompting which is a feature that was
added not too long ago to the hug and
face version of whisper and prompting
that you add context to the the thing
that's being transcribed
um and it's not a perfect solution but
it's sort of primes whisper to
understand different terms different
words that's really the simplest way to
do it you would have to experiment with
it to see if it works for you or not
and probably the longer and more
expensive and more time consuming
approach would be to gather a domain
specific data set to fine-tune
but if you're looking for a quick
solution this what what Mathias suggests
um looks like a great starting point
yeah and the idea behind whisper was
kind of that you don't really need to
find unit like it already knows a lot of
stuff
so it's nice if you don't have to fine
tune it and you can get away with the
prompting
um but yeah there's always it's always
possible to fine tune if you have the
data
absolutely
um and a final question from Discord and
before we switch to YouTube questions
um
just a second
and this question is about
um
recommendations for people who are low
on Computing resources so no GPU at home
or free collab tier exhausted what are
the recommendations for the most cost
effective way to experiment like
fine-tuning print pre-trained models
with a reasonable budget
I can give a few quick tips on that
um so if you go to hugging face docs if
you go to transform a dog so there's a
whole section on uh performance and
scalability and there it contains a lot
of
um information
on how the model consumes memory during
training versus during inference and
what are the knobs that you can turn
into
improve to optimize memory usage to
increase speed of training so you have
tools like gradient checkpointing you
have tools like gradient accumulation
you have mixed Precision training you
can combine all kinds of different
techniques to make the training more
efficient more and optimized memory
usage
um
and there will be a good place to start
I think
although it is
a bit advanced
yeah I think also like um you can pretty
much use
um you know things like toggle notebooks
you will need to create a kaggle account
um so you know that that basically
serves as like a drop-in replacement for
collab um you have limited sort of GPU
hours so I think it's limited to
something like 20
um GPU hours per week but that should
that should um effectively Breeze you
through
um the speech recognition as well as the
speech classification the audio
classification
um task for sure
um
I think I think that would be like the
like the most easiest way to like go
from like you know like a collab like
setup to like a
um
to like a title notebook style uh set up
in case like you're looking for the the
most cheapest option in terms of gpus I
think uh paper space provides like uh
student discounts and like also like
academic discounts in case like you
belong to those groups then you can
apply for those
um but yeah hope that helps
yeah I also use paper space
for my projects spare time things it's
pretty inexpensive
um
it's a lot cheaper than buying your own
GPU or doing something on like Google
Cloud
it's worth looking at which of these
services offer the best resources
if you're really strapped for resources
uh my main suggestion would be to use
smaller models because that's you know
that makes the biggest difference
absolutely
um
let's switch to the questions that we've
had on YouTube
um
starting from the very beginning
um do
um are we going to have a section in the
course on music generation
um I'm working on a project that uses
control net and music gen but I want to
know how I can use these
so I probably can answer this at the
moment we do not have uh music
generation in the curriculum in it but
we are considering possibly adding it so
this is we don't want to commit to it
right now but we might add it to the
course
as a bonus
so we have to well as of one hour ago we
have two models for music generation in
Transformers and one in defeat or a
coupling diffusers and um so it can be
something that for sure we kind of do
like a Hands-On with all of these
um but it's pretty exciting space
at the moment because it's you know like
there's so much attention in music gen
so
um yeah we can try and write something
that keeps up with what's going on
yes
[Music]
I've been several questions
about
uh transcription
um specifically real time subscribe
transcription sorry and whether you can
do this with uh whisper
transcribe speech in real time
yes
um you can I'm just trying to find
um the GitHub just that I had but
essentially like all you need to
um need to do is just create like a like
microphone object and pass it through
the pipeline and you can do it via I'm
just pasting the link on
the chart and it just works
automatically with the pipeline of
course it assumes that you're you're
running like locally on a GPU on a CPU
it's really slow uh specifically for
whisper
um but yeah you can essentially use the
same sort of
um same code that I've linked uh and
like swapped that
um like instead of the open AI whisper
based model you can swap it with wave282
and it should give you
um a more sort of streamlined
performance on CPU
um or like more faster performance on
CPU than whisper
so I think the thing to remember with
whisper is that it's sequence sequence
so you have to wait till all of your
input audio is ready before you put it
through the encoder and then you
generate one token at a time it's
actually what VBA is going to share in a
second is it's kind of like a trick to
getting past this bottleneck of waiting
for all of your audio where you wait for
a little bit of your audio a predefined
amount and then as soon as you have that
you put it through the model and it
starts generating and then you wait for
the next bit and then you start
generating and then you're going to have
a boundary in between the two which is
where you have to stitch the two chunks
together
so this is kind of like a workaround to
make a model that doesn't work real time
work semi-real time so you have to like
Define how real time you want it and so
the the more real time you make whisper
the the larger the performance
degradation
the the closer you go to offline where
you wait for all of your audio the
better the performance generally is so
this is something you have to also trade
off like how much do you value the model
working real time versus having good
word error accuracy
and full whisper is actually
not that it needs all the audio because
it works in 30 second chunks so that's
like if you if you wanted to not use
this trick then your latency would
always be 30 seconds
right and this trick I think it makes it
use smaller chunks each time so you can
reduce the latency but your compute goes
up
yep next question
um in light of the conclusions made in
Hagen face ethics and Society newsletter
number four despite it being focused on
text to image models do you plan to
encourage considering ethics during
model development
um so in the unit that is dedicated to
text to speech that's coming soon would
definitely mention ethical
considerations of development developing
such models and as well as in the docs
for this model and on the blog in the
blog when we wrote about this model we
mentioned ethical consideration because
um obviously there's a lot of potential
malicious use for text to speech
[Music]
uh models
and thank you for bringing this up
absolutely you should be training and
using these models responsibly without
with understanding
um
the consent of the data being used
concerns of the people's voices that are
being used how they're going to be used
um absolutely this has to be considered
um
do you create content using hiking face
models
yes modal models that we use in the
course they are all available available
through Transformers
and we all use um forget face
Transformers and hub and hanging face
data sets
um which are all available uh for you
open source and free
next question yeah just just
go ahead no it's not like quickly say
one quick thing like whatever you learn
in the course is not like like I mean of
course like we use hugging face stack to
like showcase like how exactly do you do
X Y or z
um you know tasks uh but you can pretty
much like use the same Concepts and and
do it without the HUD and pay start as
well right
um so like every like you can pretty
much use like any open source
um you know implementation and there are
you know plenty
um if you look out you can also like
sort of use those so I just don't want
want people to feel that they're you
know sort of marrying into like a
ecosystem but you know you're
essentially like like the course focuses
on like the foundations and like how you
can do x y and z
um things uh and their tasks
yeah I took this question do you create
content using the models
to mean like we used like GPT to write
the course but we wrote it all by hand
it's all human generated
human generated human reviewed in that
sense yes
you're right this question can be
understood in several uh ways
let me check what other questions we
have what is the next one
[Music]
um
thank you
give me a second
what do you think about developing
objective quality metrics for text to
speech as MOS depends on the setting of
The Experiment and could have some
biases this is a very good question I
think because it is uh challenging to
objectively evaluate TTS models I think
we're gonna talk about this in the unit
that is coming soon but perhaps
um
we could discuss this now as well a
little bit too
right I can probably take a stab at this
um so like typically like if you look at
a text-to-speech model
um it's supposed to do like two things
one it's supposed to
um you know generate like an audio which
you can understand and second it needs
to be able to sort of pronounce
different phonemes in the in the right
way right
um so of course like the sort of
Industry standard way of doing this is
through a mean opinion score wherein
like you have like four or five audio
samples and you you know call upon say
you know 100 to 200 sort of people from
diverse backgrounds and have them listen
to your audio files and give it a score
between zero to five right so five being
very good zero being that they cannot
understand it at all and then you
average Source course and then you get a
MOS score right
um however that in in practice is not
really feasible and you know involves a
lot of time and and you know effort just
in general
um so what we uh what we like there are
certain proxy metrics that you can use
right so for um like one that you can
definitely use this like um something
like some sort of like objective metrics
like um you know signal to noise ratio
in the in the in the output of your
um you know speech like how much is the
is the noise versus like how much is is
like speech in the
um in you know whatever audio file that
you have there are also like certain
sort of
um metrics like stoy
um I keep forgetting the full form of it
but it is essentially something that you
use for
um you know like Telecom providers use
to test like how like what's the
perceptual quality of your audio right
um so you can use those metrics which
gives you like a de facto
standard sort of um you know
like number of how
um how is the perceptual quality of your
um audio and and of course like you you
use some sort of ground truth so like
you for example you would when you train
a text-to-speech model you would have
certain speaker so in this case the
speaker can be me and then the way I say
that could be the reference audio and
then we train the Texas beach model to
mimic me right and then we compare how I
speak with how the how the
text-to-speech model generates certain
phrases so that way like you have a
reference and you have like the
generated audio and then you can compare
them and you can use like pretty much
all sorts of simple
um you know
um objective metrics
um last but not the least there are like
certain Moss models um so like moss
architecture so you have a wave 282
based uh moss architectures and um you
know so these are like models which
would train to essentially give a score
between zero to five for a given
um audio of course A lot of them are for
English but there are like some for
other languages and you can use those
models as a proxy for a more survey as
well
so yeah it's like evaluating
text-to-speech is is like a topic which
like everyone fights about and you know
there's no consensus on it uh but
essentially like what you try to do is
you try to get very close to uh
reference audio and then use
um you know certain objective metrics to
get there um more on that on the in the
unit six I think
um but yeah
all right
um anybody who wants to add anything
no okay
um
moving on uh there's a question about
Vector databases so um just the way how
embeddings for NLP models can be stored
in Vector DBS is there a similar
approach for audio
um so yes so like we have models like
Club
um I keep forgetting the full form of
Club but it's the it's it's like it's
similar to clip for image right so
essentially like you give an audio and
you get some sort of embedding out like
embedding is essentially like a
numerical representation of you know or
like a condensed numerical
representation of
um an input like like in this case would
be the audio waveform and um so in
in practicality you can essentially pass
all of your audio files through uh clap
and like you know get some sort of
representation
um out of it and then like use those and
like save those in like your vector DB
um and so on
um there are other
models for this on the Hub as well so
you know you can also use
um wave to it too to generate like
representation of your
um uh of your um audio files like
essentially embeddings
um and you can also use
um info deck which is like one of the
most more recent addition to the library
we merged it last week
um and like plenty more I'm also sure
like you can use whisper um and just get
like the encoder
um hidden
um output for that as well
um so yeah long story short you can
um save it just you just need to find
which architecture works best for you
and um and and for your specific task
and it should work
the same way as it goes for text
um thank you there's an there is another
question
um about
um generating audio and how
to set an emotion for the output
and how is this approached
I can I can take that uh
I'm like so just in general like
text-to-speech is is like a thing which
I um like research at the moment and
like have been doing so for the past two
years and that's just something which
I'm really passionate about
um but okay so uh let's
um let's think step by step uh about
this
um specifically for you to generate
um emotion in an audio you need two
things
um you need well some sort of like
guidance to the model to know that hey
you know like you want to generate this
this audio in a in a more sort of angry
Voice or in a more you know sad sort of
um voice and I'm more sort of happy
um you know voice and so on
um so what we typically do is we we
model these emotions
um in like of course in latent space we
are like we are another like sub
component of the text-to-speech pipeline
so think of it this way that you have
um you have like the input which is text
during training then you have like
reference audio which which we use to
you know generate and alongside that
we'll create a sub network uh whose sole
task is to model the emotion this you
can do with you know speaker embeddings
as we were you know saying before
um because economendings or like any
embedding for that audio would also
model some sort of variation
um in the in in in the audio as well so
these variations are known as you know
we typically call these as prosthetic
features so velocity is like how you say
so I can say I say I can say say or I
can say say you know different ways of
saying say so essentially like you you
take a model and you you model these
um sort of variations
um with that with that model and the
embeddings actually capture it and
through time and like through a lot of
training data um so you know through
like 10 000 so like you know potentially
hundreds of thousands of examples you
learn these variations and um then you
effectively get to a point wherein you
can
um you know tweak these um and then like
add emotion so to speak to
um to the to the generated audio
um like in case anyone wants certain
pointers like what you want to look for
is Taco Tron 2 and um GST like just
search these two things uh that was the
first time that we were like effectively
able to you know model emotion uh for um
you know text-to-speech systems and you
know yeah you can you can you can read
more about it or just like add me on
Discord and we can have a longer chat
about it
I've also seen systems where the input
text is uh
they add annotations to the text so bark
for example does this where you can
as
specific like uh keywords like screaming
or something and then the text will be
screamed at you
um yeah so that's another method of
doing it I think some commercial systems
also allow you to add uh
additional information to your text such
as like the speed with words that are
spoken uh the pitch and so on so these
would be additional inputs going into
the model but then of course you also
need to train the model with such data
so it's uh it's already difficult enough
to get enough training data just text to
speech like good training data so having
data with additional information about
the porosity and intonation and stuff
that's just uh that gets expensive
really fast I think
yes
um
I'm gonna turn attention back to sanchit
now because there's a question right for
you
um when you fine-tune a model like
whisper on a language which wasn't the
original model
um in the original model as a data set
what happens with the tokenizers
okay so there are there are two things
that we can do in this situation the
first thing is that we can
um do what we do in the Hands-On or so
in the in the fine tuning example in
unit five where we pick the language in
the tokenizer that is closest to the new
language that we're fine-tuning on uh so
in the example that we give we want to
fine-tune on the very and that the The
Whisper model has never seen this
language before
and um so what you have to do in this
circumstance is a do a bit of linguistic
detective work so what I did was I
wikipediaed the the verhi language and I
looked at which language which language
was most linguistically similar
and uh I saw that was the sinhalese
language and um I checked this language
and it was in the whisper tokenizer and
so whisper has seen this language during
pre-training and the reason that we give
this language then to the tokenizer
during pre-training is that we we want
to have whisper use the knowledge that
it has about sinities
and leverage that for the new language
that it's not seen before
so it knows quite suppose like um you
you know French and you want to learn a
new language probably the one that's
mostly linguistically similar is Spanish
so like if you take a French speaker and
then they um they learn Spanish it's
going to be quite similar in terms of
vocabulary and we do the same here so
whisper already knows a bit about
cenalese and so now we tell it like
the very is quite similar to Cinelli so
you could you should use this knowledge
on the new language so that's what we do
in the notebook and um
as you use your fine-tuned whisper model
you should instead of
um
like when you when you specify the
language argument you can just specify
this as synonyms then in the future like
when it's fine-tuned on the vehe in this
way it will treat the very incinities in
the same way
the other the other way which we've also
tried and pretty much gets similar
results is that you just don't tell
whisper what language it is and tell it
not to predict the language and so then
it stops making the the language
prediction
um
and we found that they're both quite
similar but
we found you know there's like marginal
performance again if you do this like
language tricking idea so
it's the one that we we went for
hope that explains
so like the whisper tokenizer that's
like 50 000 tokens in it already
so it already covers a lot of possible
combinations of characters and words
parts of words
um
if you want to like replace the
tokenizer with your own specific
tokenizer that's probably not ideal
because that also changes the size of
the tokenizer and it changes the size of
the embedding so you'll be throwing a
lot of information the way that whisper
has already learned right so what sanchi
suggested about try to reuse existing
languages and you can see existing
tokenizer is probably the smart uh
approach for whisper for other models
you might actually want to create a new
tokenizer specifically for your language
I don't think it makes a lot of sense
for whisper
I don't know if I hope I'm not lying
here uh sunshine
no I think I think that's exactly right
and the first thing you can check is
just make sure that your vocabulary is
in the whisper tokenized already so just
encode a sentence and decode it if you
get the same thing out that you put in
then whisper already has these
characters and then you don't have to
worry about any of this tokenizer
reshaping
if you don't have the tokenizers then
the vocabulary already whisper might not
be such a good model to fine-tune in
this case you might be better doing
something CTC based purely because it's
just easier to build a CTC tokenizer and
we can share like a blog post for doing
this with the new uh meta MMS models
foreign
we have about four minutes left
um
there was a question about
essentially allows you to Audio models
which we haven't touched on
um today yet and how would you
um
essentially Translate speech in one
language to another language
to speak in another language
and I think the the basic nuts and bolts
are are there right like at the end of
the day
um if we're doing for example speech to
text we're going from speech and then
like so let's assume like a encoder
decoder model so whatever encoding
speech and then we're decoding our text
right so you can pretty much use the
same basic principle and um you know you
you basically encode speech and then you
decode in like speech in other languages
and you know like you you can then like
Define
um you know certain controlling
parameters to do that but the basic
principle
um you know throughout Remains the Same
that you
um you essentially like take an
architecture which goes from like one
sequence to the other and you know then
um sort of model it uh or I will train
it that way and like of course like
you'll have to make like certain changes
here and there but by and large
um you know
the the the task Remains the Same
yeah and we have one example in uh
Transformers
I think at least one anyway uh from the
speech to speech T5 uh it has a voice
conversion uh uh pre-trained model and
speech T5 has been trained on uh text
going in speech going out speech going
in text going out and speech to speech
so they trained this on all the various
combinations
um if you have if you have the input
sequence is text and the output
sequences speech then there's like a
difference between the lengths of the
sequences that the model needs to deal
with
um we have audio going in and audio
going out uh these sequences are a bit
better matched so in that sense it might
be a slightly easier problem for the
model to handle uh but yeah like a VB
said it's uh if you have a sequence to
sequence model you've got one sequence
going in one sequence going out and
basically what you need is the right
data to train it and uh if you if you're
interested uh check out the speech T5 uh
voice conversion model that we have
do you think the recent model by meta AI
the MMS massively multilingual speech I
think it's
um a really it is abbreviated from do
you think um you could use this one for
audio to audio task
specifically for translations yes it is
the model that supports a lot of
languages
no so this is this is a model that's
um fundamentally uses the CTC decoding
algorithm and so it's just an encoder
model
um and so like if you I would encourage
you to check out unit 3 on audio
architectures and um so the the problem
with using MMS is that you're going to
put a sequence of um a sequence of audio
inputs in and you're always going to get
a fixed audio or like depending on how
long that audio sequences you're gonna
get a sequence of hidden States from the
encoder
um but you're not mapping that into a
new sequence in like a different domain
all we do is we just add a linear head
to do CTC decoding so actually we can't
go into like a different speech domain
using this for that you you need an
encoder decoder model
but you know what you can do is is is
use the MMS checkpoint convert like
speech in one language to text in that
language and then use the width
checkpoint which we've which we will be
merging maybe like in a um in a day or
or two and then you can like uh you know
uh get
um sort of speech on that and then you
can add another third model in the mix
which would translate the text that
you've transcribed
do like another language and then you
choose that so essentially like speech
from language one to you know text in
language one then text in language one
to text and language two via a
translation model and then you know use
the width checkpoint on on From MMS to
go from text and language to to audio
and language too
um yeah you could you could well if your
language was in whisper as well so if
it's one of the 73 languages in whisper
then you can just do directs
so then you go like let's say you've got
um language a which you want to map to
language B so whisper will do speech to
text A to B and then you do B text to B
speech using that the TTS checkpoint
and so you can do this kind of like
pipeline approach but you're going to
get error propagation so if the whisper
model transcribes it wrong then it's
going to say it wrong and you lose a lot
of information about how oh yeah yeah
how everything was pronounced and stuff
so it works it's not as nice and
convenient as an end-to-end solution
where everything happens in the same
level
thank you so much we are already we
already ran out of time uh for this
session but I think there was a lot of
wonderful interesting questions about
all kinds of
um Audio models and applications uh it
was really interesting to hear your
perspectives on different topics
um somebody asked in the chat what
course are we talking about so this is
the link I'm gonna drop in the chat in
case uh
yes there is
um
and with that if you have any more
questions feel free to join Discord
channel it's let me just drop that link
too
I'll drop it in a second
um
and we'll be happy to um asynchronously
pop on in the channel and reply to any
more questions
and happy learning thank you for joining
us thank you for staying all the way
Take Care thank you cheers bye-bye bye